the jurgen experience
your exercises have 100
made my knee stronger well 100
i appreciate that it's r it's really
amazing so
with those kicks
and a lot of people out there can relate
you do that because it's something you
want to do it's not like that's the
healthiest thing for your knee to go
with this i mean the amount of torque is
probably like in the thousands of pounds
every time you throw out a kick if you
add all up all you know all that force
and it's the same with jumping
playing basketball is not good for your
knees right but i want to do it right so
that's where the sled comes in because
every step that you're going backward
you're strengthening your knee
but
there's a fundamental difference between
the sled and any other exercise that i
do
the difference
is that only you move the sled so the
sled never moves you when you do squats
or anything like that you're taking some
degree of risk your the weight is going
to move you down
and then you're going to move it back
so
i last time i was in la i'm on the roof
of my apartment and i have one of those
internal resistant sleds up there and my
neighbor's 82 and he wants to join me
for a workout he doesn't know who i am
he's just i can instantly put him
on a sled
and this is an internal resistance one
that you can push and you can go
backwards i've seen that one yeah if you
pull up my instagram
i put so that anyone listening can get
the world's fastest education meaning
i'm just i made for the podcast i spent
the last week preparing
six posts in order so let's go to that
one on the top left
the current human exercise fundamental
is walking forward with a machine doing
the work for you a treadmill yeah okay
it should be the human doing the work
even pushing a sled would be so much
better you can put an older person on
pushing a sled
only they move the sled so you don't
have the
you know with a squat or something like
that
there's a lot more
chance of uh
of injury right but we we want those
effects of a squat but for example i go
six days a week i sled and one day a
week i squat you see the difference
there is that what you do six days i
every workout i sled first i don't it
doesn't matter if it's upper body i sled
first so is that how you warm up or is
that that's how i warm up
but it also it gets my cardio in
it gets if you go right to the second
post someone can see exactly the
benefits i'm talking about
you actually get a foot workout when you
push a sled for sure okay and so i think
most of us humans we're missing training
our feet
yeah
right so right off the bat and you were
mentioning louis simmons and the reverse
hyper and how it's like
how you can rebuild a back when you push
a sled you get a very similar effect
because you're not loading your spine
right so
pushing a sled
and then going backward at least as much
so i i do more backwards than i do
forward but i sled every day
so every time i work out the first thing
i do is i sled no kidding because i'm
only been doing it once a week and i've
been thinking you know like i don't want
to overdo this
and that's what's interesting is that
it's a lot easier to overdo
exercises and it's the crazy impressive
exercises i can do
that get views on posts the slide is not
interesting right but the sled is what
i've definitely done more than any human
being over the last 10 years so the best
thing i can do is just
relate
the exact you know path i took so how
does one know when they're overdoing the
sled
so
first off
if the sled had a thousand pounds on it
it just wouldn't move right so you
already have that difference it's much
harder to get into a tricky situation on
the sled
and we really haven't seen such a thing
like people have asked this a lot how do
i like what's too much
there's actually in the last five years
there's one dude who has sledded more
than me and i've made him my training
partner now like i'm like
dude like your mission in life is to
push me push me every day of my life he
slept every day as well
go look at the second slide on that my
training partner is 43 and he has
reversed his body he can dunk a
basketball he's the guy in all my posts
so
he's 43 years old he's the youngest
looking 43 year old i've ever seen
he's he can now
dunk a basketball he's completely
shredded
in the last five years
that's crazy he's outsledded me in the
last five years one-handed hang
while he's extending his legs
contracting his abs and holding a 45
pound he rarely does that
that's [ __ ] wild
that's wild what does this guy do
he's a trainer
man
yeah [ __ ] sign me up yeah he
he wrote the um
he wrote the gym book with me it's a
it's intended to be like our gentlest
starting tips for longevity